what's the truth on where and how this
virus originated and why are the
officials here and in china still lying
about it mike gallagher has been pushing
for answers like we have on the origins
of covet 19. he represents the state of
wisconsin and joins us now
congressman gallagher
first off what do you take from these uh
100 page report
to me it confirms what we've known for
months which is that fauci
lied to us he lied to congress he knew
that our taxpayer dollars were being
administered by his organization to
third parties like ecohealth alliance to
do cooperative research gain a
functional research at the wuhan
institute of virology and when
questioned about it he hid behind a
highly legalistic definition but more to
the point he was lying and the fact that
he still has a job is an affront to the
hundreds of thousands of americans who
have suffered if not died under
coronavirus and then i add on to this
the fact that we we now have the 90-day
intelligence review from the bind
administration which came back with
nothing that's unacceptable and it said
that we have we can't get to the bottom
of this until we have the co-op
cooperation of the chinese that is bogus
that is a cop-out there are a ton of
things we can do and let's start by
subpoenaing peter dazek and his entire
corrupt organization to get answers we
cannot accept these lies to be the final
answer congressman uh senator josh
hawley is demanding that fact she's
stepped down are you
absolutely at a minimum at a minimum he
should step down and we should have a
full transparent investigation to
untangle the complex web of u.s taxpayer
dollars funding this type of research
but where is the accountability from the
chinese communist party why is this
administration effectively covering up
for the chinese communist party when it
comes to this are we so afraid of
offending their delicate sensibilities
that we're not going to demand answers
after they've particip perpetrated one
of the biggest cover-ups in the history
of geopolitical relation relations this
is absolutely unacceptable and we have
to get to the bottom of it congressman
if anthony thaucy is so vulnerable to
this
why does he on every television show 24
hours a day
and how unbelievable is it that he'd be
on cnn today and not be asked about this
intercept report not a fox news report
not congressman gallagher's report a
report in the intercept
because the entire media has gone hook
line and sinker for this narrative that
was perpetrated as you pointed out in
your monologue we had scientists who had
profound conflicts of interest who were
writing letters telling everybody this
didn't come from a lab and the media
went for it and the media has been
acting as useful idiots for the chinese
communist party and they're afraid to
admit that they were wrong congressman i
look forward to your action on this and
anthony factor he's got a book tour out
maybe he'll have a
to a couple of uh tougher questions
coming his way he's coming out with a
book in about a month
all right appreciate it hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else